- man
a bunny felicidades congratulations on
the new album man how does it feel now
that it al it's--that's feliz super
filly I'm so happy I'm so excited and
I'm so yeah si si si si I mean it's so
good to be you right now a lot of
exciting things happening for you we got
to talk about the Super Bowl halftime
show because that was such an epic
surprise and you guys did amazing not
only did you crush it and it was an
amazing performance but you know it's
also important for the culture how'd it
feel to represent Puerto Rico in that
moment no that was an amazing moment in
one of the biggest moment of my career I
was so happy and proud to represent the
Latino community victory Kenya you know
and yellow out that flag I was so crazy
I'm going crazy tile over yo so was a
special moment um a really special
moment for me and my my my team my my
family you know all the Athene all the
heroic and some Latino community latino
gang you know there's a problem moment
and you know I heard that Balvin said
that he doesn't usually go out but he
celebrated that night did you party with
them did you celebrate them all I was so
focused on your album you know it was
worgen that leave that i'll i when i
finished my my performance i went
straight to the studio
Wow yeah cuz you had to put this out you
knew it was very rough right around the
corner so I mm-hmm I love that I paid
off because this new record it's amazing
it's so bad bunny you still got the
bangers in there but it's also this
emotional side you know what was the
inspiration behind the new record I want
to say it y'all go leukemia like Anna
yo I'm okay with that
I do what I want I yeah I think he's
outgoing so easy is is simple he's just
for dancing having fun so this position
was like you know goodbye
happiness nothing anything complicated
mean serious just cuz my first album
pohchamp Rae was most like emotional sad
nostalgic so for this one I wanted to
give him something you know more but you
still are nostalgic in this one it feels
very open but but in in a good way in
like in a model I feel like it's more
like you know Romano and bring a bow on
what I love it ignorant this is your
latest single your first club with such
what was like working with him oh nice
amazing he's so humble and talent yeah
so I like his music
I like the way he always put feeling on
every track and giallo MIMO and then
they assemble bumble sentimiento so I
think these are a great collaboration I
love the music video for two because it
features so many different kind of
relationships I mean everybody right
included in even same-sex relationships
and I think about that I think about the
shirt the tribute for Alexa on Jimmy
Fallon I mean why has it been so
important for you to be a voice for the
LGBTQ community especially when you know
the Latino community is machismo I think
you know me as I've seen
have a crowd that I think that needs
that message or that type of education
mm-hmm cocaine Aiello up and saw a
yellow yeah he saw and I saw case NECC
tawa-tawa so those idiots at lo siento
que important I think especially like an
ignorant video is a video about love so
the video is gonna be about love love
love is love I love that we love you for
that for sure I mean obviously been so
outspoken about that you've also really
opened up especially on social media
about your own mental health
why is that important to you kind of
share that side with your fans I think
that is so it's very important talk
about it
maybe some people need the motivation
confidence and maybe if they see bad
burning talking about it they're gonna
do the same take a talk yeah so another
available at the name la mota asean if
born is a big star and he's talking
about it i could so it takes the stigma
away a little bit makes people feel like
yeah to fill that without of per game
poor dantella less or something say it's
formal of course are you freezing for
the market or possible
absolutely what does it mean to have
that relationship with your fans they
trust you you know they listen to you
fill you and they relate you know ya
always know i'm encounter I always put
my piece of my heart on every thing but
I do music video lo que se so yeah this
mpresario Neto
I always remind myself okay so obviously
this new record is after your collab
album with Alvin you guys have been such
tight friends and he calls your little
brother what's it like to have him on
your side no well-being is my friends
it's a great person you know I love him
especially in winter Dennis's dollars
for you sempre dopamine so we have Aziz
that easy it's a it's a heat so I'm so
I'm so happy to the Canucks lol from
your boil boy they're probably
I saw you both at Coachella last year
and my mind that festival would you ever
do it again
of course yeah it's a party in Tampa I
love that you know speaking of heart
there's so many people in the music
industry that love you too
I've talked to a few of them including
Roselia I mean I love your guys's
friendship what is it what's uh what's a
night out like with Roselia and bad
bunny ha ha ha what do you guys do no
moon talent those are aligned the simple
separately and overly one song for our
oceans of vampire and overall positive
emotion forever hora de mucho menos una
musica sleeping in the studio Rosalia
ah no either okay we gotta make that
happen you know what do we gotta do I'm
ready for that I think I think okay I
love it well we know that Rosalie is
your friend I want to know who's got
your heart you you looking for love
these days do you have love yeah yeah
yeah I feel okay
from who what's amazing because the
obviously this record at the beginning
of it feels like you're talking about an
ex so you're kind of like moved on past
that yeah yeah now I'm very on delivery
and oh well what kind of qualities are
you looking for in a relationship
honesty always be honest confianza pero
lo importante impressive to me more sell
our entails alone estas en purple cave
on the two-finger said I'll gang
national final LD have an orphan son
ahora cuando
takanakuy lacking Arabic is another look
at our chrono so I guess a long after
the PCB I mean ma nothing in my look I
love your fashion choices are you having
fun getting dressed up for everything
now thank you
no see ya but a simple table yeah right
Sparta will you will deal with those you
know I changed three times for you I
wear to interview bad bunny no no have
you ever thought about maybe one day
doing a fashion line putting your own
collection out there your own clothes
yeah I think I think so it's one of my
of my goal yeah well now we are working
on my music I love it what do you want
fans to know about this record what do
you want them to know Joe's just already
a girl Carol if Lou thing I make music
just for for Picasa if you de la gente
para para el momento location preach oh
la musica cirrhotic real momento a
musica siempre NOS acompaña and tall oh
yes you do everything so well I can't
wait to buy your clothes maybe get you
in a movie would you want to act yeah
yeah I like to add yeah yeah I like I
like it
Hollywood either okay I'm here Hollywood
I'm here movie you're in the next one
yeah classiest good ass yeah be changing
so fast
[Music]